and you're so confident in UFL I mean
your own daughters should be fighting I
don't know any more stamp of approval I
can tell people like hey man yeah look
we all get we're all brand ambassadors
right yeah I make money they I've drank
this I take this you know and there's
some guys out there that really it's
like you really hey man like you know
cameras are not watching do you really
like this product you know and I've
talked to guys it's like nah man I just
they put money in my account yeah so for
people to go well you know UFL pays you
you're your owner in the company uh of
course you're pushing and I'm out yeah
but I'm actually gonna put my daughter
on The Fight Card well she's actually
one of our Fighters I don't know of any
way to really tell anybody how much I
approve of a company I'll be like hey
you know what I don't know how many
fights I have left in me maybe only one
more maybe you know who sees how that
one goes you know but uh there's only
one time that I can fight for with my
daughter on a car yeah well that works
out I'm like oh well I know where I want
to have it done at where it's going to
be the best opportunity for her to be
taken care of in the best way and that's
here under the brand